firing practice on nato's eastern flank
[Applause]
british polish and other allied troops
fighting a fictional enemy but everyone
aware of mounting tensions with an
all-too-real foe russia
the defense secretary says he's
concerned about a build-up of russian
troops around neighboring ukraine and
the use of migrants as a weapon by
kremlin ally belarus whether it's linked
or not i think what is true is there's
lots of activity in this part of europe
that is threatening security and i think
one of our responses to show that
solidarity both politically
and indeed militarily scenes like this
on poland's border with belarus prompted
the uk to send a small group of soldiers
to see if they can help
minsk accused of pushing migrants into
the eu to create friction
britain will likely send at least 100
more military engineers to build fences
in the coming weeks
this may be seen as a provocation not
just by belarus but also by russia
president putin is sounding the alarm
about british support for the other
flashpoint ukraine as well
including over a planned sale of
warships and missiles
we constantly demonstrate our concerns
on that account we speak about red lines
but of course we understand that our
partners are very peculiar and
to put it mildly they take all of our
warnings very superficially
nato soldiers see things very
differently they say they're a defensive
alliance and will only act if moscow
tests their red lines
this isn't just a training exercise by
british polish and other nato allies
this is designed to send a very real
message to russia that the alliance is
ready to respond to any new aggression
that's true for an attack on a member
state but what about if russia invades a
country outside nato
like once more targeting ukraine it's
unclear
and in that uncertainty lies huge risk
debra haynes sky news north east poland